today the doors of st. Antony's shrine
opened only for a brief moment they
offered a deeply disturbing sight dark
silent there's almost a photo negative
of terror with the gruesome human toll
cleared but the physical wreckage left
behind you can see here this is where
the bomb itself went off all the pieces
scattered around up there that's the
roof that's gone down the smells quite
something the altar far away from the
blast is unscathed Sky News was the only
British broadcaster to see the
devastation the stillness of st.
Anthony's stands in contrast to the
urgency of the ongoing security
operation this evening security forces
raided a suspected bomb factory there
was a firefight with several explosions
according to local sources a suspect was
shot and killed and in the north of the
country in a separate operation more
arrests were made a huge haul was found
shown here on Sri Lankan TV drones bomb
material fuel suicide vests along with
Islamic state insignia the group there
has claimed responsibility for Sunday's
attacks I believe that in the next few
days we'll be able to control this
situation completely just like how other
countries have faced is a vague next few
days probably wasn't the reassurance his
citizens were looking for and the
president also took the opportunity to
blame the Prime Minister for weakening
Sri Lanka's intelligence while the
country's politicians play a
self-interested blame game actual
leadership is being provided by
religious heads this Sufi mosque opened
its doors for Friday prayers despite the
government's warnings afterwards they
held a silent protest against religious
extremism do you have any hesitation
about opening today
was a no-no from the day one I decided I
will and we wanted to show solidarity to
the Cardinal and the people of the
Christian faith and Catholic faith and
since they all went for prayers they
never expected a disaster of the Saudis
won't happen as for the Cardinal himself
his message was also one of peace and
determination do you then blame the
government for these deaths we don't
know how to blame whom because now even
if we blame what can we do this people
will not come back to life you know this
is a very sad situation do you think
Christians are safe now
in Sri Lanka I think so he said no
public services would be held on Sunday
that we will not allow people to be
killed unnecessarily
a priest at st. Antony's told me that
amid the wreckage of the church they've
still been celebrating Mass every day he
said they had prayed for the people Tom
Cheshire Sky News London